Kansas Notre Dame Indiana and st. John's  already clear decision I've always been  in motion every move I make is to get  better opportunity has led me around the  world from South Sudan to Australia  where basketball stole me from my first  love a 13 year old kid they called long  body I found my calling  sacrifice was necessary leaving my  family for a new family  next stop the world stage where the  competition got real my vision became  perfectly clear  then Canada a place to focus please to  build my body and to spend one more year  with my brother Here I am still on the  move  in pursuit of greatness  I'll be declaring for the 2016 NBA Draft